there are 33 000 traditional temples in
thailand
but with its majestic white exterior
what rancoon is anything but ordinary
[Music]
every part of what rancoon is unique the
entrance is lined with ghoulish traffic
cones ghostly heads hang from trees and
arms reach up to meet you as you cross
the bridge to this architecturally
curious place of worship
[Music]
what roncoon's most distinguishing
feature is its untraditional white color
chosen by the artist to represent purity
the sprinkling of glass mosaics are an
emblem of enlightenment while the
mirrors show off buddha's wisdom shining
through the universe
contrasting the white is a gold building
the ornate restroom is covered in gold
leaf symbolizing the idea of the mind's
fixation on wealth and material
possessions
while the temple is visually stunning
and attracts thousands of tourists from
around the world when it was first
completed it received negative attention
the thai government monks and other
artists said it wasn't thai art as it
was a departure from the traditional due
to the symbols embracing pop culture
found throughout the grounds
despite that the building stands
defiantly as an emblem of tie art for a
modern world
you